Jerome Nickelback is here you feel no
fee well then look at the computer Oh
God
look at the command monitor and I think
you should look at the monitor um Tom
Cruise and badasses not go together okay
he is in action films and you just make
those faces hey I can be in action films
I can go places I'll show you all one
day have a big game no wait well this is
pretty cool I like this my I think links
if you cross me oh this is I'm evil
that's why did you kill Manon seriously
because I'm evil I just told you Adam
you should go into that laser I'm sure
it will go fine
come on you know I don't know if you
like it states the plum oh [ __ ] okay
let's do it this time sorry I forgot all
right let's all kill laners that's the
plunder I kept forgetting I'm sorry you
have to my side then China
let's old meet up in the lobby to make
sure no one does any funny bits a
horrible idea dude you realize we just
get started shooting no no no that's not
gonna happen that's not gonna happen Yin
you know why why I guess we have music
okay uh okay
ken I can trust you okay this is good
this is good
I can't bring you music we're gonna
we're gonna have a great I don't know I
just threw that let's look at UM's
dancing manis break dancing all over the
place okay all right
Adam I didn't know you were such a good
dancer I'm regardless I don't even care
anymore he's dead he's dead
why what the [ __ ] haven't shoot at
anyone what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
I wouldn't even harder rabbit if they
were really ugly I'm sorry we had a
conspiracy game don't care noscope you
bro you can't bro right you're my
montage bro you got montage bro
is that a verb bro bro bro bro don't bro
me bro you want to bro me bro bro me
I'll bro you oh I'm brewing it up I've
never brought so hard before no Jerome
go away Jerome what did you see okay
alright and what were you doing you've
got Pierre yet to work fine fine yeah
yeah this door and now we need to grate
the entire wall stay there
you [ __ ] you killed your ally you
killed your fellow traitor huh fellow
thanks Tom Thanks I'll never forget this
I never have a beef with everyone in
this game except ten I have against beef
if you know what I mean it's gonna be
happy shoot you I'm important oh [ __ ]
okay oh hi hi hi I'm innocent I'm
innocent
hey who's innocent
what why are you guys laughing stop
laughing
okay whoever is innocent sniff this
chair because he isn't sniffing okay
wasn't sin again it wasn't syndicate but
I'm gonna go and show everybody just
want to make sure I hate you guys I hate
you guys like so Haley Jenny we're all
traders apart for me this person here he
wasn't here it's pootie stop shooting
you promised we'll check yeah you're the
best detective ever
I'm innocent I have bananas please
please but don't shoot my bananas ken
Ken I don't like where you're pointing
that gun is using that voice again I
don't like that voice okay he's using
that voice listen we're gonna stop voice
I don't trust it I knew it I was uneasy
using that voice he's using the voice -
I am a fire starter you gotta wait till
it starts but I'm sorry Gert I should
have known that the brains are kotas
better also versa beautiful [ __ ] I
cannot wait just come over here we are
your paintings the beste pieces came on
through a tree matter it's okay I wasn't
trying to kill you
you injured me I'm really hurt stop it
it does not matter
I am very gentle in my grave who
shattered against me advice everything
so quiet okay okay hey don't leave the
platform but stay on the platforms and
again is a trainer everyone on platform
everyone on the platform otherwise and
no needs if anyone holds an a - you can
your your game can you should be here I
don't say how did that happen that is so
yeah I kept fit I'm too fat Wow sorry
that was twitch twitch twitch 20 where
are you
go I'm not gonna I'm not gonna kill me
minx what the hell you guys gonna
inspect my body in the main hey don't
you may know [ __ ] me it's me I'm right
behind you I could've killed okay well
if I can trust you say that okay you
stay over there you stay over there how
I want you back and see you there's
[ __ ] you're going I don't want you
goddamn gun
I don't want you to my cream my grenades
hey here take your gun back
guys guys I don't want to like burn
anything but I am definitely innocent so
it's one of these Adam Adam where are
you Adam
come back oh oh the hell are you playing
oh where are you going pewds Shh
why are you laughing why are you
laughing
don't laugh I don't like when you laugh
no laughing aloud I'm here [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] panicking stop jacking the
goddamn door clean my room yeah I'm on
Jerome [ __ ] nickel Bank you
don't [ __ ] with me okay okay okay can I
trust can I trust
hmm up with Ken if I down with Ken okay
well then put away your gun if I can
trust you I'm a detective
then I'll put up with my gun what the
[ __ ] seriously yeah you can trust me
you're the best I don't trust you I
don't know if I get your see of you
really I don't like your attitude
do I have to do to make you trust me I
must do something there's something I
can do
wait Adam who are you shooting in I'm
not shooting it at anybody I know
shooting it
Adam what are you she can really I'm not
shooting stop it stop I'm sorry together
stop stop okay everyone together
everyone together none of this betrayal
stuff okay okay okay where's Tom I'll be
your friend let's all hug Tom
can't we just hundred Oh Tom Araya let
us hug you know
for Tom he's one of us let's go party
yeah where's Adam
okay oh okay I'm sorry I'm ink I'm sorry
about that okay
Michael high five he's shooting what is
he your onto the floor he's underneath
you
we're in the vents that sneaky little
rat look what you've done
hmm oh man that seems like such fun oh I
hear something my tits off why do you do
that why do you do that how did you find
me
it may be easier for you to win if you
didn't kill all your teammates the
beginning hey can you kill me playing
times not one of the same team